you know I've been in industry for long
enough to say that historically we hated
Tech it would always be like the robots
are never going to take our role or
whatever whereas right now the industry
is so open to Tech welcome back to
another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host Hisham
Aziz and on this week's episode I sat
down with Simon Brown we turn business
away with 10 pounds 72 000 pounds worth
of business within the first 12 weeks of
Ultron Simon's been on an interesting
Journey these last six to nine months he
sold his recruitment business he's then
joined the company that bought his
business and more recently became the
managing director of digital periods so
sometimes there's a fine line isn't
there between self-belief and the
arrogance in terms of there are other
ways you can do things we have a really
honest and Frank conversation around how
he got to that point how did he build a
one million pound business without
making a single Business Development
call don't worry I really get him to
explain how he did that how did he come
to the decision to sell the business how
did he get it over the line how do you
deal with the impact for those that
worked for his organization when he
never initially planned to sell the
company and these past six months now
he's joined the business now he's got
the sale through how has it actually
turned out how does it feel to now have
sold your business we discuss all he
shares all some really great insights in
this conversation for any aspiring
recruiting entrepreneur who wants to
exit or sell their business one day
enjoy the episode Simon welcome to the
podcast thank you thank you for having
me happy Friday
I've been recruitment Friday no I
appreciate you jumping in obviously I
had someone let me down and I know that
you know when I saw what happened with
your business I messaged and I was like
mate we have to get you on the Pod to
talk about this at the appropriate time
so it sort of worked out this way so I'm
really looking forward to Breaking this
down with you and I thought let's just
get straight into it for people
listening yeah so obviously it's been a
interesting period for you because
obviously when you came on the podcast
last you was on the Journey of building
your startup yeah 51 yeah and then in
January of this year it was acquired by
the rethink group yeah and I think today
what we're going to do is focus and talk
about you know what the digital 51 look
like to be even in a conversation of
being acquired
um you know how did you get there what
was that experience like and then we'll
then talk about you know what the
journey has been like actually on the
other side I know we're early on on that
Journey but still I think a lot of
people are told this is you know this is
what's going to happen this is you know
what's going to happen when we do this
and then you're now in in the thick of
it six months into we're going to talk
about that so why don't we why don't we
just start then
um with you know digital 51 yeah what
did that obviously I made some notes but
why don't we start with like
when did when did the sort of
conversations start or when did Simon
initially have some of these ideas of
I actually might sell my business which
had been going for you know 18 months
which isn't a very long time when did
that start happening for you it did it
did happen around the 18 month mark So
the plan was never to sell the plan was
to drive for 10 years to build a
um employee-owned business and
essentially step away at the 10-year
Mark so that that was the original plan
there's no denying it first 18 months um
in some respects went better than I
expected financially performance was
superb
um the impact and the approach and the
style and all of that was brilliant on
on the markets that we were going after
um so there was lots of positives in
some respects however we were struggling
to grow
um I was struggling to grow the business
and we needed to grow at a faster rate
of heads in the business than I was able
to financially drive through cash flow
um bearing in mind completely
self-funded completely privately owned
by self and therefore
there just wasn't able to grow in that
way so I started to think about
investment at that point you know bank
loan investor
in putting my own more of my own money
in releasing shares I started to think
about how can I raise money so at that
point we'd gone from five to eight and
we'd hired in ones and twos or ones and
then a couple of people hadn't worked
out with read hired from that side I
wanted to grow at 10. so therefore do it
in a chunk of five and then another
chunk of five and that required
investment so I I went to my accountant
first things first what can I get from
the bank what can I leverage you know
based on my accounts are in a good
perspective you know in a good spot
they offered me some money from there
which was interesting but that's bank
money so it didn't come with any upside
it was just here's your cash away you go
what I thought is if I've got some
investment from someone in our industry
I might also gain from that support for
me it is lonely I was I was lonely
um maybe an investor would be someone to
bounce off someone to talk to I had a
non-exec but the that wasn't necessarily
driving the way I wanted the outcomes to
for me so so I I then started to just
talk to people in my network in the
sense of if I was looking to raise funds
to release anything between five and ten
percent of digital 51 would you be
interested and that was that happened at
the end of summer
[Music]
um
22. okay so really bang on the 18-month
Mark and that's where the conversation
started around what the business looked
like what the value of the business was
because you had to you have to know all
that information to ask people to invest
money and then you sit opposite people
and you start talking about it and it
went from there okay and I appreciate
that so I want to ask you to break down
what the business looked like when it
got acquired because I think that'll be
really interesting for people because
you've
you've achieved something I know there's
you know you're really excited about
what's to come but ultimately you've
achieved a business event that a lot of
recruitment business owners you know
really aim for at some point and a lot
of people don't get there and you manage
to you know get that over the line and
Achieve that but I think it's probably
worth noting and we'll come back back to
this but obviously correct me if I'm
wrong but you wanted to grow in two
chunks of five because your model wasn't
the typical contingent model it was a
talent partnership model yeah so what
you were seeing is you know with you
sharing was like you was getting in you
know you was getting in the rooms with
some great businesses yeah they bought
into the way that you're doing it but
you knew if you committed to a hiring
project of 30 which what the opportunity
was there's no way you're gonna
deliver that or you wouldn't be able to
deliver the service that you wanted to
so that was obviously a bottleneck which
is why it was like hang on a minute I
can get in these rooms we just need more
you know more power in inside our four
walls to be able to deliver on these
projects that I know that we can get
yeah like on the money I was you know
really lucky myself and Adrian who were
leading the business from the front
natural better with clients love the
market love Business Development love
getting out seeing people I went to see
one of the largest privately owned
creative comms agencies in London which
was like totally my wheelhouse I love
that industry space and they were wanted
to do a an intake for 25 account
managers
um it was like this was this was early
22 and the market in that creative Comm
space was booming there was a huge
demand for account manager because of
um suppressed hiring in the past two
years and I can remember getting the
train home thinking it's this is so
exciting I would love to work with this
brand but if they give me this project
not a am I going to deliver it part
of my French you know what am I going to
do
um because we didn't have the resource
in place and then we
just to be honest that didn't come off
and you know when I was I was worried
that early in the year that didn't come
off and there was a bit of me that was
relieved it didn't come off which is
insane right and then 89 pitched for
another piece of business which was
European business and being honest we
sort of Tanked on it a little bit we we
didn't nail it at the end
um but again what they were talking
about I was like we are really because
we were 100 fill rate right on
everything we got we filled every single
opportunity that didn't get pulled by a
client because we were that partnership
model so
you have to know if you're in the room
with these people we're going to deliver
and we were getting close on the from
the resource side
and I wanted a bit more slack in there
which is why I wanted to grow a bit
quicker also the market was insane for
salaries at that moment in time so I
knew I was going to have to get people
without
um you know full-blown recruitment
experience and take them on that journey
and we were fine with that but again
that means you unfortunately probably
have got a higher chain rate if you're
gonna churn you know 30 of of that then
you're gonna hire 10 and lose three
possibly four so it was sort of
accounting for those types of things
that was the demand well that was my
thinking yeah so why don't you just very
quickly just like high level explain
what a talent partnership product looked
like and felt like just because I feel
like this might be you know quite
important when we're talking about the
acquisition because that might have made
you actually Stand Out above you know
the other recruitment owners that say I
want some investment I want to grow my
business I feel like you can tell as an
attack but just describe to us what is a
talent partnership model what how did
that work and operate what does that
look like well it is ultimately as well
why it became more attractive from an
acquisition perspective because
ultimately we could plug in our offering
to someone else's solution which is what
ended up happening with rethink so if
you think about contingent recruitment
um you know I need to hire this can you
get it for me fill that seat
um that's like tried and tested and
that's where recruitment came from right
and then you've got the full Outsource
model where you know you sign an RPO
contract for one two three four five
years and you go down that route we sat
right in the middle of that so not
necessarily embedded so we weren't
embedded on client-side or what have you
but we will take a projects of like five
hires and above where a client you know
you've got to think about our target
audience was two areas it was either the
creative space or it was scaling
startups in the tech space and you want
to grow from you want to add five to
Fifteen hires say in the next six to six
to nine months in product Creative Tech
you don't want to build your own
in-house Talent team you don't want a
contingent recruiter because they don't
understand you enough they're not you
know immersed in your culture then we I
had a financial offering around that
where the the partner would pay us a
monthly fee and we would deliver
outcomes against it
um from that perspective so we were we
weren't physically embedded as and we
didn't sit on their sites but we were
embedded in what they were trying to
achieve and we delivered our Solutions
as opposed to we will fill these roles
for you we were delivering outcomes for
them from that side so the thinking
behind it was one fast growth fast
growth coming out of covid
um huge demand for perm and from a
business ownership perspective it was
reoccering pair model uh repair Revenue
reoccur in pair and Rev whereas the
historic problems in the pair Market are
as spiky you know you have a brilliant
month then you've got to rebuild and you
have a dreadful month and what this
allowed us to do was essentially we
didn't do contracts so it allowed us to
have reoccur in pair
um and and grow in a slightly different
way and also I just believe that there
was a hole in the market between full
Outsource and contingent and a lot of
contingent recruiters weren't really
looking for this because their desks
were hot because of the stairs
just quickly if you don't mind yeah
again we want to try and make this as
tangible as possible for people let's
just break down what a like minimum deal
look like so what was like the minimum
so let's say I you know I was your
target client and I fit the five over
the next six months I knew that I wanted
to get two developers in that time Simon
I wanted to I needed a product person
because of that and I needed two
creative uh Talent what like firstly
what what in and around would be the
minimum you know monthly current Revenue
end up agreeing with me yeah and then
two what did those deliverables look
like that were expected and you agreed
to because I think that'd be helpful for
people well I will answer that but also
we had a partnership approach to
everything so we would do a partnership
for one hire but that partnership was
called the key hire program
um or the guaranteed
um the eight week guarantee so we would
we had
Partners who came to us to say we need
to hire this one person head of product
head of development
um head of client services in the
creative space and we would partner with
them on that so we would guarantee to
get that job to offer within eight weeks
loads of people would call that
historically retainer but in a retainer
you lose your you pay your retainer and
the agency doesn't feel it you lose it
or it gets spun onto something else we
had a partnership offer in there for one
role which was you pay us half up front
if we don't get it to offer by the end
of the eighth week then we give you that
half back now we never had to do that
which meant that we could offer for us
partnership wasn't based on a minimum
number of rolls or hires the cheapest
ever one we did I don't mind sharing was
four and a half Grand a month okay and
that was in the creative space and that
was with a client who had done 10 hires
with us on a um on a six project and
then a four project and then they wanted
to do something over a longer period of
time and we did a commercial deal that
was four and a half thousand pounds a
month before then that was our cheapest
one that we ever did
um
I think the benefit of
um the biggest deal we ever did the
benefit with it was it was six month
deal yeah paying x amount on one say 25
Grand if you wanted to use that number a
month over a six-month period and the
partner
needed to hire a number of people during
that time and then halfway through that
Pro that project they didn't need to
hire those people anymore because of a
pivot in their business but they still
paid the rest of the partnership so in
the partnership model if there's
economies of scale for the hiring yeah
partner they get all of they get more
than just they get a help we used to
have a huge stack of data Insight Market
Intel we would help them with their
recruitment process we would do lots of
things for them but if you needed to
needed to hire 10 people and then you
got to five and you didn't need to hide
the other five you still paid so you
still paid that monthly so the reason
that the big one was good was the truth
be told their business pivoted halfway
through and they didn't need to hire so
for three months they paid us that
partnership model which is like
commercially superb but the flip side of
it is if they had gone the full duration
then we would have made less Revenue per
higher than a contingent recruiter and
then just really quickly typical
deliverables but besides having someone
offer an eight weeks what were the
typical deliverables that you would say
and for that every week we're gonna have
a checking call you're gonna get an uh
insight into you know the amount of
people that we've reached out to what
are some of the the typical you know
deliverables that you would say we would
also give you this yeah it's funny even
being honest because you've got to think
as well this was the height of the
market so it was about outcomes in terms
of it was about that so we had lots of
metrics in there in terms of we will
provide you with data we will provide
you with salary benchmarking we will
provide you with
um you know but really it was about
delivering rules and also certainly in
the scale UPS because they were like we
you know it was about speed they wanted
people quickly okay cool fair right so
really useful context then so I guess
from what it says online you can
obviously fill in the gaps here from
what it says online obviously uh with
that acquisition of
um your business by rethink at that time
the next income was 1.1 million what was
the ebit and we were half so at that
point we're running 50 drop through rate
so the the plan was to build
um a million pound NFI business in the
second year so we would generate a
million pounds worth of NFI bearing in
mind we're perm so I wasn't like
turnover was irrelevant
um however we we fell short in that
second year which was a big sort of
frustration but the goal for the second
year was to do a Million quids worth of
NFI and for costs or like nothing to
ever get above 50 it was always the goal
and then there's seven people at the
point of sale you said yeah yeah Okay
cool so that's the business they bought
I think why don't we let's just break
this down a bit so in terms of I think
what you obviously shared with me um on
the prep to this which I think have been
interesting place to start was you said
the conversation started around October
yeah the deal ended up actually
happening going through on January yeah
so these things can often take longer
than people anticipate it totally but I
think what you said where I want to
start obviously I'm not bothered about
actual numbers but I think what you said
to me was you said initial number yeah
they did their due diligence so like
yeah NASA and that's not happening
um and then you obviously got to play so
what why didn't you I think what would
be good is what didn't stack up or after
do the limits a good Simon look I don't
think it's you know I don't think it's
there because of this reason what what
did you you know put more value in yeah
but then when someone you know an actual
acquirer looks it and go yes Simon
that's not as valuable as the thing what
were some of those things that maybe you
misestimated to stop there yeah it was
funny because we were talking about 20
investment and we we sort of you know
they were like for 20 investment and
they were really happy to invest at that
level and that was going well and then
these were happening over lunches and
then in between one of the lunches we
had a conversation was about well maybe
we'd want to require all of it and we'd
want you to come with it and you know
our business could you know one we've
got an outsourced business in rethink
we've got agency businesses and digital
gurus and infinite talent but we've got
this Gap in the middle
um and then also there's you you elf
type thing so
would you be interested in all of it and
then I was also like I'd started to
think about it so I was like would you
be interested in buying all of it so
they said yeah so we went back for a
lunch and I'm sort of a no I'm
going to tell you my numbers first and
then I'll follow it all up in Black and
White and the person I met with was like
yeah great love it whatever so we went
through the numbers and it just all went
too well he was like yeah yeah yeah yeah
that sounds great yeah yeah love it yeah
yeah and I was like okay
um and I came out and I was like
that went really well um so I Then
followed that up in email
these are
like this is real now this is real this
is what we went through these are the
numbers
um
I'm not gonna lie he replied to that
email I was like yep all looks good what
we're going to do is we're going to
finance people to check it out and we're
gonna do this on the other
and one at that point I hadn't even
decided that I wanted to do a wholesale
sell however uh the the price that I'd
put out the number he was happy with
yeah
then I spoke to the finance guy
then we met for lunch and he was like
dude this is not happening and I was
like what are you talking about
um and he was like I get this
partnership model and it's reoccurring
rev and what have you bought it's a
startup and it's put him
um and yeah let's like have a reality
check and it just shows I guess the
value of a really good numbers person in
any business that you know I guess what
was against me holding out to get what I
wanted
numbers wise once I'd started to really
commit to a deal was if I'd have
probably been a year or two further down
the line I would have had a lot more
traction to demonstrate whereas the
reality is at this point 18 months with
a forward pipeline of about three months
we always had you know there's a lot of
risk in there for a business don't get
me wrong I still think the brand was is
and was banking so you know that was
great but there's only so much price you
can put on what's you know Goodwill and
brand so yeah they started to pick at
bits of the concepts behind my valuation
if you like well there's some of the key
bits and I think now because yeah I know
what's useful for people is
look there's one thing going yeah I'm
gonna sell my recruitment business and
you thinking like what it's worth why
it's worth this like like you just said
like you put it all down had that really
positive meeting and then you had a bit
of a really reality check with someone
that you know gets in the nitty-gritty
what were some of the one of the two
things that maybe in hindsight like you
know what maybe I did put too much value
on that or maybe I did uh over egg that
or maybe yeah that shouldn't fair that
shouldn't equate to X multiple like what
were some of those things that maybe you
thought would yeah what what did it what
were the fun some of the one main one or
two reality checks that you gave you
yeah well to be clear I still think my
price is right yeah the the biggest
um probably one of the biggest mistakes
I made and one of the biggest thing so I
didn't take a salary for two years so I
hadn't it so when I looked at my
profitability
um which was I didn't take a salary for
two years because I didn't want to take
a salary for two years I didn't take a
salary for two years because it was part
of my plan to build the business I was
actually always going to take a salary
on a you know month one of going into
the third year was always planned that
way what I wanted to do was reinvest as
much as humanly possible and I'd made
some I'd made plans going into the
startup that financially financially
would take care of me so I didn't do
that I was just taking a dividend if and
what like as in at the end of each year
being completely candid my Approach was
like the day before Christmas Eve I'm
going to take out a dividend at that
point and that's me done for the first
two years I've done all my planning
around that what that did is that
inflate your ebitda because
fundamentally you haven't got your own
cost in that so the very first thing
that the CFO did was right your salary
is this applied it straight to that
number and that reduced the
profitability of the business straight
away so I hadn't just clicked sorry yeah
what I've done is I've taken the ebitda
of the business and applied a multiple
to it which is the way that you should
do a deal and I I looked at the last 12
of months and I'd forecast the next 12
months and I was I was taking a bit of a
gamble because I took the average of
that whereas in reality you should
probably take the backward blocking
number
um
and and yeah it's from there that's a
great learning but but what I hadn't
done was factoring my salary now where I
got I would say where I got frustrated
and where we disagreed is
I I still saw it as the true ebitdar of
the business without my salary in
because I'd made the decision not to
take a salary so it wasn't but we need
to put this amount in for you because
that I hadn't needed or wanted to take
that money for this that was intentional
it wasn't like taking it because like he
wasn't able to no the cash in the bank
was never a problem you know we were we
were profitable in month one we started
trading on the first of March we made
profit in month one in the first nine
months of the business we only didn't
make profit month by month once so cash
in the bank was never an issue cash in
the bank to the scale of go and hire 10
people was an issue which is why we were
looking in for investment so I always
felt that that was a bit of a bone of
contention however I could understand
the logic behind it you're coming with
the business because I think again when
you go to do a deal
some people look to do a deal and exit
some people look to do a deal and earn
out I was looking to do a deal and go
with it because I was looking for the
opportunity inside that organization
which is why I got interested in the
deal because I was interested in
rethinking the group and the brands
within it
so because of that they'd started to
factor my cost in a little bit more but
to be honest I was probably a learning
that whether I took a salary or not I
should have factored a salary into my p
l going into year two because every time
I sat with someone over Finance they
were like these numbers are brilliant
and then they were like what are you
getting from it
and then I couldn't show a salary and
they were like that's not right you know
so it caused me a problem hey everyone a
real quick one from me this podcast
would not be possible without our
amazing podcast Partners Vin cherry and
Source breaker because you listen to
this podcast you're able to get your
hands on exclusive savings on both of
these award-winning products if you're
all a growing recruitment business you
have to check out vincere who are an
all-in-one operating system for your
growing recruitment business with Source
breaker if you want to make sure that
all of your recruiters have the best
tools on the market to stand out and
beat their competition then you have to
check out Source breaker use the link in
the show notes in the comments below and
you'll be able to get yourself exclusive
savings on these amazing products yeah I
want to thank I appreciate you sharing
that so I wanted to make sure that we
went through how you then ended up
structuring the deal which I think will
be interesting for people but just
quickly just popped into my head as you
were going through that
obviously like I said I'm not bothered
about understanding we don't we all need
to know exactly the multiple that you've
got I don't care about that but I think
this is about what other people can
learn but I'm assuming you've because it
on our preparation for this you're now
involved in potentially looking at other
brands you could acquire and you're
maybe having a bit more of these
conversations and as we discussed in the
last last podcast like you've had a lot
of exposure to these types of
conversations because of your history so
my question is from all these
experiences so far maybe more recent
conversations and being around more
people like this Finance person yeah if
I'm a recruitment owner and I mainly
have a predominantly perm recruitment
business what do you think is a
realistic multiple of my ebitda to
achieve from yeah yeah it's interesting
I was on I was actually on a call
yesterday exactly you know 60
um contract V perm split business
um been going for half a dozen years
looking at looking at an event and you
know
um sat on the call with a finance guy
and they're looking at a three
multiplier okay um off that side died I
think it would it's like a bit of a
politician's answer that it will always
depend on you know what you know the
business itself the makeup are the other
owners or the founders are they going
with it are they doing an air now who
control you know in a contract heavy
business how much contract have you got
um with certain members of the team so
if you've got 10 people who build
contract in your business but uh 40 or
50 of your revenue is set with three
members of that team that's gonna that's
that's gonna bring the ebit that's going
to bring the multiple down
um you know from that perspective so it
will always it will always depend I also
think as well any
multiplier is important but the business
is also worth what someone's willing to
pay for it so it's like when you go to
buy a house a house might be valued at
certain amount if you want to pay more
or less that's that you know beauty is
in the eye of the holder right so
ultimately you need to apply multiple
um if
if you're doing an MBO
um so you know management team are
buying it out then you should really
look at you know ebitda performance for
the last 12 months because that's the
reality if you're doing a trade sale
then you might look at forecast three
bit Dar for the next you know um six to
12 months because
um you're looking at the future value of
the business from that side
um you know so there's loads of
different things and there's much more
qualified people than me out there I I
find it interesting I find it
interesting that we don't there's not
more merger acquisition MBO deal talk in
our industry in general and I also find
it interesting that there aren't that
many deals done every year because most
agencies are owner managed and although
some of them have the ambition to do an
event they're normally profitable
businesses so they end up holding them
and some hold them for too long so long
yeah and from that side so yeah
you know depends on your business with a
straight paying business your multiple
will always be lower unless you're a
Goliath and you've got some
um you know recurring perm rev in there
yeah how did you structure the deal then
so we we did a deal that was based so
the other thing for me was I wanted I
wanted to go with the business first of
all so I wanted to go into rethink which
meant that I also had to then negotiate
on a job in the sense of you know what
where are the needs within your business
what what is the future of digital 51
within your you know group at that point
the group had three businesses within it
infinite Talent digital gurus rethink
itself werewolf digital 51 sit within
there so there was sort of three parts
to the deal and being honest one was
like how you know how much you're gonna
pay for it and what's included in that
price so what was included was like the
client relationships the candidate
database
um the brand itself all of the knowledge
and everything that went with our
product offering and you know some of
what I'd like our secret sources I like
to think behind the scenes so that's
like the first part the second part is
what's gonna you know what's gonna
happen to the brand moving forwards is
it going to get unsetted is it going to
remain as as a legal entity you know
who's going to own that legal entity and
then the last bit was what's happening
with you Simon yourself in that
perspective the big things bizarrely for
me were not The Upfront price because it
sort of it is what it is you know we've
been around that round about you know
the first round about have been really
good for me the second round about I
think it was still good but it just
wasn't as good as the first one
um the second bit was for me was around
the legal ownership of the business and
whilst I was super excited to be going
into rethink and and I am excited to be
inside it I also I didn't want to give
up the legal ownership of digital 51 and
I wanted some caveats that if for
whatever reason this didn't pan out of
the journey that we wanted it to that I
could get that business back what I
wasn't looking to do was sell my
business have nothing to do with it ever
again so really important factor for me
was I actually won a caveat
milestones for the first two years which
is what we did that if this doesn't work
and by work we you know define success
then you have the option I can take it
with me yeah and I can leave and that
was really important for me and then the
last bit was what's my job going to be
yeah so why don't we let's focus on that
now then what your job was going to be
obviously you told me what obviously you
tell me when we're preparing for this
like I was like right how what does
Simon actually do within this
organization within this group and you
broke it down like this but why don't we
talk a bit about what the you know
overall strategy and plan was for Simon
to impact the refund group but you said
at the moment if we were to split up in
your weeks like Monday Tuesday you're
running a you know Circa 50 person
um recruitment business on the digital
gurus and infinite brand when's their
first day you're involved in the market
team
um and you know the functions around the
RPO model right
um and then
um and then you'll also then you know
now one of the five people that are
leading a 200 plus people you know
recruitment based business and group
you're back in the boardroom having
those conversations
and you are developing products and
services and you know now thinking right
how can we continue you know rethink
strategy who could we be interested in
buying what companies do we need to be
aware of submergent acquisition
strategies as well right you just nailed
it if anyone in the business is
listening to this and wants to know what
you know what do you do every week Simon
well is that the initial plan uh no
so the talk is about yeah what was like
you know the second part of that deal
yeah right Simon join us yeah this is
what we're thinking which you also got
excited about these things happen is
obviously you're you're engaged and
you're excited with what you're doing
but what what was the initial plan so
the initial plan was really the infinite
Talent brand
um was
um sort of it's it didn't really you
know it didn't have a crossover with
digital 51 in that sense they own their
space very different type of agency
however digital gurus and digital 51
don't just share a name you know lots of
market synergies products creative
technology you know that is what DG was
built on you would definitely refer to
say well you've modeled large parts of
digital 51 on that I have because I
loved that business that brand the pink
in digital 51 comes from the pink in DG
so but they are heavily a contingent
agency then you've got rethink which is
an outsourced provider large-scale
managed service on the contract side
large large-scale RPO on the perm side
so like five six thousand term hires a
year type scale
there was this really big gap in the
middle between where one business ends
and another one starts and what fit
nicely in there was you know digital 51
this partnership offering Bridge the Two
Worlds so that that was the original
plan combined with that you know
increased scale and scale and sales
velocity within the rethink group
themselves you know acquire more logos
more Brands more RPO and managed service
clients on the contract side and that
again was my history for him 10 plus
years ago so that was the original sort
of thinking combined with that I had
some would say some success with
marketing digital 51 over the time there
was a head of marketing or there's a
head of marketing in rethink but he
reported to the CEO the CEO by his own
admission if he's listening he's not a
natural marketeer so there was an
opportunity for me to lead a marketing
team on a scale that I'd just never done
before so really exciting from there and
that was the original pitch the original
pitch was our holes are here this bridge
between these two brilliant
organizations getting them to work
together and also offering our client
base and new client base something in
between which was digital 51 combined
with that if you can grow our existing
portfolio and you know harness the power
of marketing you know we've got half a
million eyes on those brands in terms of
LinkedIn followers alone but
maximized Roi from that is is minimal so
it's like it was a brilliant opportunity
so the cell was yeah sit nicely between
the drive
um those partnership sales through
digital 51 so keep that entity we do
projects within the RPO business but it
didn't have an identity so it was like
put that project RPL which is sort of
sub 12 month
deals put them into digital 51 give it a
brand give it an identity bang let's go
so that was the that was the original
that was the original plan that makes
sense so how did it go in reality then
what
oh so you said like what you found
yourself doing now yeah yeah so now how
did it go yeah in reality what what
happened is that
um I guess you know 250 person
organization being completely honest I I
had forgotten the inner workings of
those bigger well I'd sort of just got
out of the rhythm of those bigger
organizations and been seven years since
I've worked in a business that size lots
of moving Parts within there and you
know sort of end of March start of April
time there was essentially the
opportunity that we actually need
we've got a need for leadership across
digital gurus and across infinite
um very different needs
um one needs hand on Hands-On leadership
and one just needs you know action maybe
well just wait did you got brilliant
couple of brilliant directors at the top
of it just just to help them yeah just
to sort of you know keep them true and
what have you from that side but
essentially can you take a more Hands-On
role with the leadership of our agency
business which
was like
I'm not gonna lie it was a really
exciting conversation and bearing in
mind my history with DG in particular
and my passion for that business and all
that goes with it but I was always
nervous that it would come at a cost
because they're consuming businesses you
know 50 person agencies operating
operating right in the heart of you know
the spaces that they offer it operating
at the moment where the market is in
general
I guess the opportunity to lead them
comes about because of a bit of a change
so I was super excited but I was worried
about the impact it would have on the
original plan if I'm being honest in
terms of this is gonna make digital 51
take it back
redundant is a harsh sorry my friends
how on Earth do you Market a brand as
brilliant as digital 51 is against the
the Beast that is DG you know DJ's a
power brand in my opinion you know huge
followers really loyal client and
candidate base and yeah so I was worried
that it would get lost in that and then
combined with that
um it would drive me more towards
contingent recruitment which is fine and
not who's who if you cut me open that's
where my background was but my belief
system has moved more towards
partnership and you know
yeah and DG is is brilliant and I will
always say it is however it hasn't
productized which is a mistake in my
opinion and therefore again opportunity
well what Better Business to productize
than digital gurus like what an amazing
opportunity however that takes time
because uh the team within that business
used to selling in that way absolutely
not are they up for it absolutely but
then you've got the the skills Gap to go
on that journey and all that goes with
it which selfishly I thought that's
going to take away my time from from
other things like integrating digital 51
with yeah and that's they've been the
cost I would say how do you feel about
the deal now
bang you've just hit me there
how do you feel about it uh good I I
feel good um I'd be lying if I didn't
say that digital 51 got lost in the wash
there's you know I'm pretty sure being
honest with that yeah every week someone
will reach out to me and say we missed
some of your content we miss you know my
feet I the best you did a great job of
that yeah well thank you the um I'm
gonna be snippet in that by the way the
best
Outreach I've had in the last couple of
weeks is why is my feed not full of
purple pink and white anymore like that
was on a Saturday morning yeah that
killed me big time but wait what a
moment like how good is that so I would
be lying if I said that digital 51
hadn't kept its brand
um our brand present it's not you know
from that perspective I still believe it
can I still think that the basis of the
original deal makes absolute sense I
think this might not happen as soon as
you may be anticipated well I think what
we need to have a think about now you
know possibly over sharing a little bit
is I think the plan was never to Sunset
digital 51 because it was it was good it
was a standalone offering or what have
you I think we need to have a think
about the longer term objectives because
if digital 50 digital gurus sorry if DG
has gone a seriously productized could
you incorporate yeah I mean it should
should be incorporate in that way I
appreciate you sharing that I think look
I think really like kudos to you because
like I speak to so many different
recruitment businesses we're always
talking to someone about training
getting the most out of their people and
oftentimes recruitment owners are really
good again and they're in their own way
and want to be the person that's still
the top performer bringing in the best
clients all that and I think kudos to
you in the sense of like you've
definitely have a lot of humility here
to be like I'm you know I'm I put a
number on my baby that I've been that
I've built I've had to let people go
that are part of the journey you're now
obviously being asked to go Simon like
we needed to be a bit selfless here like
we think you could have a great impact
here you're now maybe thinking about
actually everything I've worked towards
a digital 51 productization do we
actually now just bring that under there
and roll that into DG and I think yeah a
lot of people uh wouldn't do that yeah
well so I respect that well thank you I
should also build look and I think
obviously what you're able to do is you
are take you're being willing to zoom
out and you know we're playing the long
game here and if you're zooming out and
you know what if I do this now and in
five years time this is what things look
like that excites me and I'm
happy to do that so yeah definitely and
you know being honest I I love digital
51 and there's days I wake up and I miss
it I should be clear I wasn't the top
performer either you know you know that
was Adriana long long before me
um so I I do miss it in some respects
however I am better in a bigger business
and a smaller business there's no
denying I've realized that myself I feel
more comfortable back in a bigger space
um back in a bigger organization
um and you've got to it depends where
you are on your little journey what
you're trying to achieve where you are
you know where you are in your like life
I'm you know I started later I I
arguably should have done it 10 years
ago if I'd have done it 10 years ago
would I have gone down this route no
maybe I wouldn't or maybe I would have
stayed true to it for a little bit
longer but you look at the opportunity
in front of you and the opportunity in
front of me with rethink was they were a
really interesting point you know they
did an MBO themselves 12 months before
really interesting Journey for the next
two or three years
where do you want to put your chips yeah
exactly that's not right or wrong I
respect that yeah I massively respect
that it's all right last
um 10 minutes here then yes why don't we
talk about let's just get into the the
the granular of maybe the lot I don't
know how recent it's been the what you
were just talking about but I think
obviously a lot of people listen to this
will working we'll work in the agency
recruitment business or own one probably
do a lot of contingent maybe they do
some partnership retained or whatever
curious I was just getting your article
up on around like why 2023 is a great
year to be in uh recruitment but I was
just thinking now we're going into this
business they said Simon really need
your help yeah you think you could be
really well positioned out these Brands
let's just focus on DG because it sounds
like that's one that's more Hands-On
yeah what were the things uh that you
wanted to get you know uh abreast of as
quickly as possible of that business so
you could know where you need to be
impacting thinking about you know what
is the dashboard that you put together
like right I need to see what is our job
to fill ratio how many clients are we
with like what was that initial
dashboard where you know you had to get
a grass or to go right this is what we
need to be focusing on or this is where
we're going to focus first what did that
initiative like because I think that'd
be interesting yeah for me it's like I'm
a big ratio's fan in the sense of how do
we make our money yeah how do we deliver
our NFI how do we generate the revenue
that we generate what does that look
like how long how how long does it take
us to get on new roles and new projects
and then when we get them on how how do
we convert them and fill them so for me
what I wanted to understand is you can
see a number on a spreadsheet right you
can see the p l last 12 months this is
what that looks like it's gone up it's
come down it's whatever it may be like
for me I'm straight on the floor I'm
like I walk in a million miles an hour I
just took a picture on the on the way
around before
um I met you which is like bullet gold
the balls in the china shop and I'm like
I'm straight in boiling the china shop
so like straight in what is beneath this
Revenue how many jobs and how long does
it take to fill them and what's the fill
rate and what's affecting the fill rate
and how can we influence but I
ah sort of love and hate ABC jobs uh
adult silver bronze whatever you call it
I'm not interested in BNC I'm
all in on a and I sort of always have
been I don't understand why you'd want a
c job I don't understand what client is
sat there thinking I hope I'm a seizure
yeah you know they're just not doing it
tell them they're a c job and then try
and convince them to become an a job and
if they don't then don't work with them
type thing so for me I was looking at
the mix between when you've got a brand
like DG you know they have people
knocking on their door day in day out
you know we had a
125 things come through the door last
year of substantial value
um that didn't even get fully delivered
on because of the outbound work that was
going with it so that's like 125
opportunities of anything from one roll
through to ten roles that because of the
mix in the history and what have you
from there so for me it was stripping
back what is underneath this NFI you
know how how do we make that money in
the sense of you know how do we convert
those deals and and at what rate do we
do them and I think that's where our
opportunity sits because
because of the way the Market's been
being honest we have got a mix of ABC
jobs and I don't think an agency like DG
to be biased should have C jobs so
what's the best of putting any effort
into seeing jobs you mean the thing is
you're just hitting there on the head
there right you're not going to put any
effort into it then then don't have it
on your board yeah don't
don't devalue that organization by
letting them think do you know what I
hate is this term is if someone comes
along they'll send them over who's
coming along
what bus stop is that happening at if uh
I'll tell you what is this uh JavaScript
developer walks past I'm gonna whiz him
or hear your words you're saying when a
client says that no a consultant would
say it to a client why I don't
understand is why all right so why does
a client okay Simon sounds good life if
I find someone yeah I'll pick them over
what I'm going to do is I'm not gonna
why does any organization hear the words
he said I'm not going to actively work
on that but if someone comes across my
desk I'm going to whiz them your way
no do not do that and to be to the
hiring organizations no don't accept
that because there will be other
recruiters out there who will be like
yeah I would love the challenge of going
to fill that for you it's why it's why
we created the eight week guarantee
um at digital 51 is I really like that
we're gonna go and find it for you
um you know we didn't have a massive
database to sell against in terms of you
know I hate that sell we've got 200 000
people on our database so how many are
you looking for work right now how many
are you speaking to every week
everything we did was sortably sort of
hedgehunt you know tell us what you want
and we'll go and find people who fit
that bill for you so under that lens
that's why I don't like ABC jobs from
that side so to to get under the Crux of
the business you need to take that NFI
number and you need to split it down how
many placements does that represent at
what average placement fee and what's
the conversion rate that's where I start
then three so what so what's what's top
of mind right now in in order for you to
positively influence things uh two
things we need to do we need to
productize definitely
um because our offering is too broad and
it is too contingent in my opinion and
then secondly we need to use more modern
tactics you know I famously said to you
we built over a million pounds in uh
digital 51 without ever making a BD call
that's because we were using modern
tactics in the background really uh
sophisticated Outreach content-led
Outreach Automation in that Outreach
um
Tech and people combined absolutely does
not need to be one or the other in fact
it shouldn't be one or the other but if
you put the two together that is strong
and you know I've been in industry for
long enough to say that historically we
hated Tech we would always be like the
robots are never going to take our role
or whatever whereas right now the
industry is so open to Tech but we don't
want to go the other way I think there's
this balance So within digital gurus
again the the team are doing too much of
the heavy lifting where Tech could help
them that doesn't mean we need less
people what that means is we can
generate more opportunities more out of
each person by using the tech yeah so
productization and yeah thinking about
your overall Business Development
strategy and what that needs to look
like yeah and I think I just think that
just productizing in general I was this
morning before I came to met you I was
on the RPL side of the business and we
we've a really cool idea of product
there that we're going to test in the
next seven days and about a different
way of how you can buy that type of
service which historically has been
known for
really long sales cycle and what have
you and we're going to flip it right on
its head and make it like really easy to
buy really quick to buy really easy to
access
um just like free trials
um
do you read books yes I do read books
thank you for that yeah this is like not
everyone's a reader yeah I'm I'm a
really if you come across Alex Hall
Mosey yeah I have not no so you should
read a book called 100 million dollar
offers people listen to should read that
the reason why I bring it up it's really
impacted my business and I think the way
that you're talking about there it's
actually really missed opportunity like
don't fall into the Trap of light we've
always done things this way no like how
I love that eight week guarantee and
that that's something that you may have
been in uh like if you were to read this
book that might have inspired something
like that because like there's so much
power in a great offer yeah you
just feel stupid to say no to yeah and
like there's so much that you can
experiment with do like what I love
about that eight week guarantee is like
you're saying look you're paying up
front but if we don't fill it you get
that money back 100 like you'll you'll
commit but at the same time there's no
risk yeah and like there's like with
that productization it doesn't mean
straight away you put it in the buckets
of contingent retainer whatever like you
can you know you can offer up your
services however you want to yeah
definitely and like there you can have a
lot of fun with that and it's and if you
Center it around when we speak to
clients what are the main challenges and
problems that you know they want us to
help them with what do we always find
themselves helping when we visit you
know growing their brand is it you know
interview processes is it data analytics
can we package that all up to say this
is digital gurus X products it's called
this this is what you get for it that's
that yeah like that's just such a missed
opportunity for people I love it I think
it's such an exciting that's why I put
that post up what I didn't say is the
recruitment the recruitment Market is
brilliant right now and I've had
a few people reach out to me and say
that I didn't say the recruitment Market
was brilliant right now I mean in my
opinion it is depending on what you
recruit for what I said is a brilliant
time to be in our industry which it is
because innovation has something that
that the industry has historically
struggled with there are still
Consultants out there now building their
desk off spec right spec has been around
before email you know people will tell
you the stories about spec in Via mailer
as in physically putting stuff in the
post and sending it out to people I I
don't be honest good right that's okay
but do I believe that specking is the
right way to completely build out a desk
no I don't so I think you productized it
in the things that you believe in and we
at digital 51 for example
it was like a cult in some respects we
believed in what we were doing and
therefore if a client didn't want to
work with us or a business didn't want
to partner with us we're like great
you're not right for us anyway and at
the same time we turn business away we
10 pounds 72 000 pounds worth of
business within the first 12 weeks of
opening because it was we had everyone
on 14-day payment terms privately owned
privately funded business as in me and I
had a business saying we're on 60 day
payment today I'm like yeah thanks for
that no I'm all right we'll just move on
and they were like well and they said to
me you're really going to walk away from
72 000 pounds worth of potential because
he's not going to pay me because six a
day that actually means 110 yeah
and it's like no we're not going to do
that in that sense it's not who we were
I mean it did help that they weren't in
core market for us but all of so it was
about staying true to this is who we are
right we do these things and we had a
couple of wobbles along the way where we
would get
um you know we'd get things that come in
but once you're a partner I had a client
ring me we didn't do Finance at all my
first desk 17 years ago was part World
Finance so I know it from 17 years ago I
had an agency PR agency London's hottest
in my opinion the F FD rang me and she
was like I need a finance assistant you
just know what's inside out is there any
chance you know anyone and I said to her
I know that job so let me pop around
let's have coffee tomorrow tell me what
you want I'll go and find it for you
obviously didn't plus I just knew how to
find that person didn't plaster it all
over LinkedIn that's what we were doing
so yeah we came out of Lane a little bit
but only with Partners so we productized
we believed in what we were doing and
then we just bang that gym relentlessly
and if people didn't believe in it we
didn't work with them and you know from
that side till now I think it's a really
exciting time because you can productize
in that way and it's never been easier
to Market because of the tools that are
available up to do out there to do it so
if you're not in an environment where
you can do that type of innovation or
the organization you work for isn't
innovating in that way then you know
people will say to me is pay I'm gonna
die is this the end of perm are we on
the long run payment recruitment is
never going to die as a concept because
permanent work is never going to die but
it definitely evolving so therefore if
it is evolving we need to think about
how people buy that service and why are
they buying that service and then tailor
Your solution to that to that yeah
yeah and I think just to add my two
pence on that what I really like about
that when you actually have that
approach you saying that we really
believed in it when you actually take
the time to equip your team with what
your actual products and services and
why it is what it is because our clients
ask for this and we help them with that
it actually gives everyone a lot more
confidence yeah I mean into the product
I presented to the business so we like
Adrian and I we would hone and change
our pitch all the time and we would
either pitch it to each other or pitch
it to the business you know on day one I
did a welcome meet and I pitched the
products and I and I built the
presentation around right I'm going to
pitch you what this is and why we do it
now and the guy's like love it and then
we did that continuously one thing I
wish we did more of recruiting in
product they do the thing called the
product tear down so they they take a
product they'll get the product owners
product managers
um the developers designers they'll get
them around the table and they'll tear
down the product in terms of right what
are all the holes in it and what you
know what what could we do differently I
we should we should have done that
because there was a couple of points in
the first year where we were cutting
through but we definitely could have cut
through a bit better if we'd have looked
at our own
sort of blind spots yeah there's a diff
sometimes there's a fine line isn't
there between self-belief and that
arrogance in terms of there are other
ways you can do things I think we'd have
if it would have had a bit more of a
tear down mentality
and or really brought some other people
in and said right we're gonna pitch you
you know take your feedback yeah it
gives you feedback for it I'll never
forget the first time I pitched it oh
sorry the first time I pitched to a
client
Eddie was sat in the back of the room
the client clearly was not having it
they were like no it's not awesome they
weren't buying it and I started to chase
the cell you know just because you
believe in it doesn't mean you don't
want it and also you know I wanted the
revenue and there's no denying it and I
put the phone down and she was like
they're not bad enough and I was
like No And she was like why did you
chase it in that way
um you know
and what happened is the client raised
something that I hadn't thought of there
we go
so we never pitched it in that way ever
again I went home that night rebuilt the
pack redid it and we never we never
pitched it in that way again but that
was like the one that got away I think
if we'd have done a bit more a b we a b
tested
definitely in the second uh second year
we didn't a B test at a time at the
start it was all we did everything alive
yeah so I'm been a pleasure thank you
thank you take care thank you so much
for listening to the episode I hope you
enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode